[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
72 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Happy to have you back to San
Francisco and very excited
to talk today about
not SRE but CRE.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Customer
Reliability Engineering.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and we
have, nonetheless, Luke Stone.
Can we say the father of CRE?
MARK MANDEL: Sure,
I think that-- yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So, you know, he's pretty
much the best person
we could get for CRE.
He's here for this episode, so
I'm pretty excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, super
happy to have him hanging out
at the booth with us.
Then after that, we're going
to talk about the SRE things
and our question of the week.
Talking about, why can't
I have a 100% uptime?
I want 100% uptime.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I want 101.
Now-- like why no one
offers 100% uptime,
and if they do they're lying.
We'll talk about
that at the end.
But before, as usual, we
have cool things of the week.
And we have three of them today.
The first one is a pretty cool
opportunity for any startup
out there doing
machine learning.
We have a competition, it's
called Google Cloud Machine
Learning Competition-- you know,
it's not a very original name--
but basically if
you applied to it
you can get up to half a
million dollars in investment
opportunities, and one million
dollars in GCP credits.
There's many other prizes,
but basically the whole point
is if you're doing
machine learning now,
you can just apply.
It's not a specific vertical
of machine learning.
It's just machine learning.
So I guess it's a cool
opportunity for anyone
out there doing cool stuff
with machine learning.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and it's worth
noting that we're pretty open.
So teams don't have to
be using Google Cloud
Platform to be eligible.
It is US based start-ups.
So if you're just
basically doing machine
learning in almost any sector
on almost any platform,
and essentially using
any tech, then we
could be interested in
seeing what you're doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Next we're going
to be talking about
something that I'm
pretty sure people that do
machine learning-- especially
at scale-- are going to
be pretty excited about.
We wrote a paper and
published a blog post
about the performance of TPUs,
the TensorFlow Processing
Units, and it has
a lot of detail.
MARK MANDEL: It's super cool.
The TensorFlow Processing
Units are custom chips
for doing TensorFlow processing,
specifically for that task,
and it's pretty cool.
So we wrote a blog post about
the performance improvements
we can see from running
workloads on sensor processing
units versus GPUs
and against CPUs,
and I'm going to read this
because I sound super cool.
The TPU achieves better
energy efficiency
than conventional chips.
Achieving 30 to 80
times improvement
in tera operations of
computation per watt of energy
consumed.
So basically it
does more for less.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is amazing.
There's a graph, that is not
the easiest graph to interpret,
but basically it says how much
more performance you can get
per watt in different systems.
And basically we have two TPUs.
The faster TPU achieves almost
200 times more performance
per watt than a
CPU, which is a lot.
So, definitely
worth it, especially
if you're running TensorFlow.
There's no better place
to process TensorFlow
than in that TensorFlow
Processing Unit.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
here's a good one.
Have you ever used a TPU?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, have you?
MARK MANDEL: Well, have you
ever used Google Search?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, actually, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Have you
ever used Google Photos?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a very good point.
MARK MANDEL: There you go,
then you've used a TPU.
It powers all those things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very good point.
And the last cool
thing of the week
is a very cool thing
of the week that
comes from one of our
dear coworkers, Bill Prin,
he is a developer programs
engineer for Google Cloud.
He wrote a chrome plug-in,
it's called DeepBreath.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
if you're a little angry
and you find yourself writing
an email that could potentially,
I don't know, get you fired.
Then this is a
plug-in for you that
will let you know that
maybe your email is getting
a little negative, and it will
give you a little pop-up saying
you might want to think
about maybe turning that
down a little.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is pretty funny.
It uses the Natural Language
API, and what it does
is it's able to figure out if
your email is very negative.
And at some point when
this core of negativity
goes too high, or
low in this case,
it will warn you
with a pop-up saying,
careful this email is
getting pretty negative.
Which is pretty funny.
MARK MANDEL: You know,
maybe I'll install that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
that the cool thing
is that the whole
thing is open-sourced.
So go check it out if you
have never used the API.
You will see how to use it.
It is actually pretty
simple and it's
a very nice example
on how you can build
cool stuff that is also useful.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome!
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with our friend Luke
from the CRE team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds
good, let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: I am super excited
to have the most amazing Luke
Stone here from the CRE team.
How are you doing today, Luke?
LUKE STONE: I'm fantastic.
Thanks for the great intro.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Before we start talking about
CRE and customer reliability
engineering why don't you tell
us a little bit about yourself.
What do you do at Google?
What's your role?
Who are you as a person?
LUKE STONE: Sure.
So, my name is Luke Stone.
I am Director of Customer
Reliability Engineering
for the Google Cloud Platform.
I've been at Google as
an engineer for 14 years.
I started off doing tech
support for AdSense.
And I'm really into doing
technical partnerships.
I think Google is an
awesome technical company
and we have a lot
to offer to people
who want to be awesome
at technology too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, we've
done a couple of episodes
where we've mentioned
the concept of CRE,
but what is it for you?
LUKE STONE: CRE is
applying the wisdom
and best practices of Google
SRE to our cloud customers.
So SRE is site
reliability engineering.
It's basically Google's
answer to DevOps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We've
got a bunch of episodes
with Paul Newson and also
other people not Paul Newson.
We talked a little
bit about SRE but SRE
has been there for
quite a while, right?
CRE is pretty new.
When did it start?
How did it start?
LUKE STONE: CRE started
about six months ago
because we realized that our
current strategies of providing
tech support and
documentation to our customers
was just not sufficient
to help people actually
build meaningful stuff
on our cloud platform.
So let me take you back.
I joined the cloud
about two years ago.
At that time we were offering
tech support to our customers,
and this was break fix right.
So something breaks, and
then you open a ticket
and you fix it.
And this is a great service
and absolutely necessary.
It catches everything that
falls through the cracks.
But why do things need to
break in the first place?
MARK MANDEL: When
you say things break,
do you mean break
on Google Cloud
or break on the customer side?
Or both?
LUKE STONE: Well, there you go.
That's the main problem here.
When you're building
on the cloud
you get access to a
ton of technology.
But now your
application is made up
of half of our technology
and half of your technology,
in terms of your application
code and systems.
So we really need to
work together and think
of your application as
one technology system
that we can collaborate on.
And not just a typical
engineering team
to vendor type relationship.
Because the APIs are
vast, and we're really
tightly integrated.
What we did two years ago was
try to make our tech support
response times better, and make
the quality of the responses
better.
We noticed that even the act
of making a tech support ticket
takes several minutes, right?
And if you're working
on an application that
has a four nines
reliability goal then
you're only allowed
four minutes of downtime
a month so you're gone.
So we really need
to figure out--
so that wasn't going to
cut it, and we needed
to figure out a new strategy.
So we looked around the world
and said, what's better?
There's a bunch of stuff
out there in terms of DevOps
and people trying
to do operations
in a more modern style than
the typical developers hate
the operators, and the operators
hate developers, style.
But the one that is
most natural to us
was Google Site Reliability
Engineering and Google
SRE because all
the teams at Google
operate according
to these principles.
So I thought, what if we
just apply these principles
to your customer application?
Would it work?
And so let's give it a shot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what
does that mean exactly?
Does it mean that
whenever someone
wants to build a new
system they're like,
hey, I want to
run these huge web
servers serving millions of
people and I have an f1-micro.
What's going to happen?
Or how does it work--
how does it look like?
LUKE STONE: That's exactly
the kind of scenario
we're trying to address.
So what we do is we
do the same thing
that Google SRE does
with Google applications
when they're going
to go production.
We have this thing that's called
a production and readiness
review that we do
internally to Google.
And we have adapted
it to make something
called application reliability
review, for your cloud
application.
So if we were to see
your cloud application
running on f1-micro we would
say, OK, there's a risk here.
[LAUGHING]
People say, well,
what's the risk?
Well, the risk is that your
input traffic is unbounded.
Do you have any idea of how
much traffic you could get?
No, I don't have any idea.
OK, let's do some capacity
planning and modeling
and see how much traffic
you could possibly get.
Oh OK, now I have an idea.
OK, let's do some load testing
and see if that instance is
going to stand up to it.
Oh, it's not.
OK, let's try to develop some
playbook, some procedures--
MARK MANDEL: Let's have
two micro instances.
[LAUGHTER]
LUKE STONE: Yeah, exactly.
And ideally some automation
to help your application
automatically scale.
But the thing we noticed
is that Google applications
are designed to scale
from the ground up.
And we have a lot of
infrastructure and practices
and history in Google
and building web scale
applications.
So the SREs at Google have seen
hundreds of these applications,
but at most companies
people are working on one.
And it's their first,
and it's probably
the only one they're going to
deal with for the next couple
years.
So we have a lot of
expertise that we
can share, a lot
of value I think
we can give by just telling
people about what they
are maybe going to
run into a little bit
further down the road.
MARK MANDEL: Now,
I'm quite curious,
obviously without naming names--
and I've seen some blog posts
on this particularly as well--
what are particular
lessons that you've
found working
SRE/CRE for customers
who are looking to come on board
with Google Cloud Platform?
What are some common
pitfalls that people kind of
run into on a regular basis?
LUKE STONE: The best answer
I can really give to that
is there's this book
called "The SRE Book."
MARK MANDEL: We might have
mentioned it a few times.
LUKE STONE: It's basically a
collection of all the stuff
that SRE has found
over time that
threatens the reliability
of your application.
SRE is really a
set of principles
that lead towards an
iterative process of improving
your liability over time.
So, it kind of works
for almost anything.
The core principles,
just to say them again,
are know what your SLOs are.
And SLO is a service
level objective.
So it's basically what
is your expected uptime,
or what is your desired up time.
And then have a consequence
for missing that,
and we call that
an error budget.
So at Google a
typical consequence
is if we don't meet our SLO then
we stop pushing new features.
And we use the
development time instead
to improve the
reliability of our system.
If you start with that it
starts to align incentives,
and then there's a
lot more incentives
you need to align between the
developers and the operators
and the system owners.
Until you can get to a state
where every time something bad
happens the response
is a positive response
that ensures that it
won't happen again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
curious about how that exactly
works when you are on CRE.
Because do you actually
tell the customer, oh no,
you cannot push
any more features.
How does that happen?
LUKE STONE: That's
a great question.
So the very basic way
that it works in SRE
is you have a post-mortem.
So if something
goes wrong, and then
you do a post-mortem,
which, there
is a very structured
approach to it.
You come over the
timeline of events
and you establish
some basic facts
so everybody is in agreement.
We use a blameless
post-modern culture,
so if you broke something it's
great that you raise your hand
and tell people what
you did exactly.
So that we can learn how
to avoid it in the future.
So we do blameless post-mortems.
And then we go through what
went wrong, what went well,
and what we're going to do to
prevent it happening again.
And it basically turns into
a list of action items.
You can see how this will
work to eventually squeeze
reliability risks
out of the system.
But in the very
beginning you don't
want to just start waiting for
things to go wrong and then fix
them.
So we can leapfrog ahead and do
an application or reliability
review.
We sit down and we look
at your application
and we use our expertise about
what has broken in the past
to try to guess
what's going to break
with your application
in the future.
And we go through five or six
components of your application
and try to identify what
are the biggest risks
in each one of these things.
We'll color them red, orange,
green, in terms of risk level.
We think about it in terms
of the impact of the problem.
Is it going to take your
site completely down?
Or is going to make it slow?
Or is it just going to
be an inconvenience?
And then the frequency.
Is it likely to
happen once a day?
Or once a month?
Or once every couple years?
So we can make a
matrix and think
about what's the potential
impact of each risk.
And then we'll give
you a report and say,
this is what we
think is the risk
profile of your application.
They might have two
dozen things in it.
So for each one of
these things we'll
say here's maybe what
we would suggest you do.
But then, really, you're in
charge of your engineering team
as the customer and you're
building this application.
So, you can take
this information
and you can take it or leave it.
And we fully understand that.
So if you want to fix all those
things, that's super great
and we will help you do it.
And we will advise you
on the best way to do it,
and will help you connect with
the right people at Google
for feature requests
or product gaps.
We'll also take action
items on that list
as well for ourselves.
To build things that
will make it easier
to support your application.
Like for example,
if your application
uses a database that is
subject to some hotspotting
because a sharded
database like a data
store or a Memcache service, we
would consider building tools
to identify hotspotting.
To make your application
more reliable.
So we both take
actions off this list.
Then the deal is, if we can get
all the critical action items
off the list then we can
kind of go into a next phase
where we can operate it together
with some shared context.
So now we're pretty
sure that it's not going
to crash for no reason at all.
We're pretty sure
we squeezed out most
of the predictable reasons.
Let's agree that if we're
faced with an outage situation
that we will jump on a bridge
together and start debugging it
together.
That's kind of what we call
shared operational fate, which
is really the end state
of a CRE engagement.
That's the state
that we would love
to get to because it's this
state that most resembles
the way that Google
SRE teams work together
to keep an application going.
MARK MANDEL: So it sounds like--
OK, so for CRE it sounds like
the difference between CRE
and SRE is that you seem to
be doing more up front work
than you would do in an SRE.
Is that correct?
LUKE STONE: I would say
it's about the same.
I mean, it's very interesting
because the SRE team at Google
does not support
all Google products.
One of the principles
is scarcity,
so you make sure
that you support
the most important ones.
And then you give
people an incentive
to work on their own reliability
so they can get to a point
where it's fair to engage
with another operational team.
Because you've done
your homework and you've
done all the basic things.
So in Google SRE,
usually the way
you get access to
an SRE team is you
go through a readiness review.
And then you polish off
all the known problems.
And often it takes many months,
like, a year or 18 months
to really build trust
with the SRE team
that your development team
is thinking about reliability
enough to invest SRE
resources into it as well.
In that regard I think we're a
little faster to market in CRE
but we try to use
the same principles.
MARK MANDEL: OK cool,
so there's actually
quite a lot of similarity
between SRE and CRE.
Really it's just the end
user more than anything else
LUKE STONE: Yeah, and
my job is really--
so my job within the CRE team is
I'm the customer lead for CRE.
So what I do is, I go through
all the practices of SRE
and I try to figure out which
ones actually apply only
to Google, and which ones
are possible to generalize
to all the customer base.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So to get ready
to get SRE support at Google
I'm imagining that before
you get the readiness review
there's some kind
of documentation
that the teams can go
through and basically
pre evaluate themselves before
they go to the actual review.
Is there such a thing
also externally?
Like if someone or
some of our customers
are like, oh, am I good enough?
What are the best practices
that they should be following?
LUKE STONE: The thing
to start with is SLOs.
That's really the
tip of the spear.
The SLO is really your
contract with the rest
of your organization
about how reliable
you expect your
application to be.
And it's easy to say, but it's
kind of hard to think about.
So imagine in a case where
your application goes down
for one minute, but your
CEO happens to be using it
right at that minute.
They're going to page the ops
team and scream real loud.
But in reality if you have an
SLO that's below five nines
then that's probably OK.
It's within the expected bounds.
You need to have an agreement
across your organization
that you're not going to
drop everything and focus
on a problem if
it's within bounds.
And on the other hand, if
the problem is out of bounds
then you need to be
able to say, OK, we're
going to have a
consequence and we're
going to change our
behavior in a known way
when we go out of bounds.
So it's a lot easier to
prenegotiate this stuff,
because it takes a
while to negotiate.
It has a lot to do with
headcount and product release,
feature velocity, and when
things ship and go to market.
So it's going to be
a little different
in every company I think.
But at Google we use this
concept of error budget, which
basically says if
your reliability is
below your target and
it looks like you're
going to miss for the
month, you stop releasing.
That helps to reallocate
your development effort
towards reliability,
bugs, and stuff.
I mean, everybody has
a reliability backlog.
It's called P3 in
your bug queue.
MARK MANDEL: Does that
mean the CRE team will
share SLOs or possibly
SLAs with the customer
once they're engaged,
is that how that works?
So it's kind of like a
group mentality, I guess?
LUKE STONE: That's right.
So what we're trying to do
is distill down the interface
between our two subsystems.
We're running the infrastructure
system, basically,
the cloud computing platform.
And you're running
your application.
And so we want to
figure out what's
a really good contract between
our two groups about when
we alert each other.
So we want to try to think
about your application
as being somewhat
of a black box.
Usually we own a bunch of
networking and infrastructure
at the front end--
load balancing, external
networking and stuff--
and then we have
your application code
which is in the middle.
And then we have a lot
of services like storage,
or PUB/SUB, or something
on the back end.
So we try to think about what
would be the indicators that we
could both observe,
at the same time,
at those boundaries
that will tell us
that the applications
is not performing well.
And if we can agree on
a few of those things,
let's say, we'll look
at the load balancer
error rate and latency.
We can make a graph
of that metric
and we can put it in a place
where both of our teams
can see it.
So now we have what
we call a shared state
about what's going on.
And if someone has a concern
about something going wrong
we can both look at that
graph and see the same thing.
We can say, oh
yeah wait a minute,
errors are way, way, out
of bounds, let's act.
Or we can say, hey look,
errors are actually in bounds
let's hold off for a second.
We're not going to hit the red
button and page of the world.
So it helps a lot to get
into a rhythm of knowing
what to expect from the other
team's behavior over time.
And it helps to build trust
and helps to build reliability.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we talked a little bit
about what happens when you
are about to miss your SLO.
What about when you
are way above your SLO?
Do we do something with
that extra error budget?
Or does that never happen?
LUKE STONE: That's
a great question.
What we see a lot, is people
are being really conservative
about their applications.
At Google, one thing we've
done that's very impressive
is to focus on our
feature velocity
and how fast we can ship things.
And to be thoughtful
about trading off
how fast we can ship versus
how reliable we're going to be.
So, often I see people erring on
the side of being too cautious.
They want to have only five
minutes of downtime of year
when it turns out
the internet has
an hour or a half of
downtime and if you have
a mobile application
you might be
unconnected from your
application for many hours,
or even days a year.
People over optimize
for reliability
and miss the chance to ship
features and get good velocity.
So what we're trying
to provide is, really,
a way to manage your reliability
according to your business
goals.
MARK MANDEL: So I was reading on
the announcement blog post that
was talking about CRE
and everything like that
and it said on there,
additional cost of zero dollars.
What?
[LAUGHING]
LUKE STONE: Well, that does two
things that are very important.
First of all it
sets the expectation
that we're going to
have to work together.
So it doesn't actually
make it easier
to run your application
reliably if you give me
a suitcase of money.
That doesn't actually help.
The problems are often in
the design of your service.
And does it have any features
to auto scale or to drop traffic
when it's overloaded?
Or to reshard when
it has a hot shard?
I can't really solve those
with a suitcase full of money.
So what I really need
from you is I need time
with your engineering team.
So the additional cost
is actually zero dollars
but it's fairly heavy in terms
of engineering investment
I want to work with the
tech leads of your services
and be able to manage
to do less with them,
meet with them regularly, and
be in constant communication.
Because that's
really what it takes
to operate things reliably.
The second thing it does
to offer zero dollars
additional cost is it
gives us the ability
to hand back the pagers if
the service is too unreliable
and if you are not
doing anything--
if you're not,
basically, holding up
your end of the bargain.
In Google we have
this concept as well.
It's not because it's intended
to be executed frequently.
All we need to do
is show that this
is a dynamic that can play out.
And that gives people
a strong incentive
to actually carry their
end of the bargain.
Because really what we're
trying to do here is
create a partnership.
MARK MANDEL: So if you show up
with a the list of 12 things
and they're like, no
we're not gonna do that.
Then you're like, OK, then we're
not going to do our bit either.
LUKE STONE: Right, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we kept
on saying the word customer,
and we've interviewed
some of them that
are some of your CRE customers.
We talked recently, in episode
68, with the Home Depot.
THE Home Depot.
Also we interviewed
at some point
Edward Wu from Niantic
that built Pokemon Go.
What other customers
can you tell us about?
LUKE STONE: One that's very
interesting is Pivotal.
We've been working with
Pivotal on their Cloud Foundry
product, which is basically
a way to build applications
that can run on a cloud--
a private cloud
or a public cloud.
With a lot of services
for the developers.
The developer doesn't
have to really think about
where is their going to run,
or what services can it access.
Their concept is, here's my
code run it on the cloud,
I don't care how.
So that works really great
because we have a cloud.
They have a lot
of software that's
kind of in between the
developer and the cloud
and we're helping them to
understand how that software is
going to scale, how it's
going to be reliable,
how to monitor it on our cloud.
They're working down a list
of bugs right now of ways
to make it more reliable and
I think it's going to be--
the nice way that
impacts the marketplace
is that it really
scales our effort.
We can't talk to every
single customer one on one.
But if we work with Pivotal
to make their Cloud Foundry
software really reliable
then lots of customers
can benefit from that.
And we don't have to
explain the same concepts
over and over and over again.
MARK MANDEL: So we're getting
a little bit close to time,
but that's OK.
So, plans for the
future for CRE?
Where do you see
this thing heading?
LUKE STONE: I'd like to work
with our biggest customers
first.
The people who can really
invest the most engineering
effort with us.
Because I think
we'll learn a lot
that can be spread
out to more customers.
Over time, of course, SRE
values software and automation
as a primary technique
for getting things done.
We're going to use our first
engagements that are really
person to person to learn
use cases and failure modes.
And then we're going
to develop tools that
will avoid this in the future.
My plan is to work with,
like, an order of tens
of customers in the first year.
And then an order of hundreds
the next year, thousands
the year after that.
So we'll get to the point
where we have some impact
and you're getting some
value from our team
even if you're not
talking to us directly.
We plan to-- we'll have
features show up in Google Cloud
that are reliability features.
MARK MANDEL: All right, well
we are running out of time
unfortunately.
I'd love to talk to you
for hours and hours on end,
but is there anything we haven't
mentioned you want to plug
or that you just think is super,
super cool, that people should
hear about that we haven't
had a chance to talk about.
LUKE STONE: One thing is
that SRE is, as a concept,
is getting a lot of traction
in the DevOps community.
And we just had SRECon here in
San Francisco, it was awesome.
There were hundreds of people
here who were really into it
and they were all
adding a lot of value
and sharing a lot of ideas.
So we want to be a conduit
of that kind of information
out to the world as well.
And we'll be at Google
Cloud Next in New York
City and Seattle coming up with
dates available on the Google
Cloud Next website.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great!
We'll have links
on the show notes.
I guess it's time
to say goodbye,
thank you so much for coming
and spending this time with us
and letting us know
so much about CRE.
Hopefully looking forward
to having you again sometime
soon to tell us about how
is it growing into hundreds
and thousands of customers.
LUKE STONE: We'll
see you next year.
Thanks, Mark and Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thanks so much to Luke
for such an
interesting interview.
I've learned so much about how
we interact with customers when
we're building big stuff.
Very, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, super happy
to have Luke on the podcast.
It's really interesting
to hear about how
we are engaging with customers.
Especially in enterprise
level on the sort of support
we're able to give them, which
makes me super happy to see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's basically,
they're not our customers they
are our partners on building
cool stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, it is
that different approach,
I really like it.
So I think it's time to go
to our question of the week.
Today, the question of
the week comes from again,
Rokesh, Rokesh Jankie.
We answered one of his
questions on episode 70
about protocol buffers.
As soon as I sent him
an email saying, hey,
your question has been
answered he was like, well,
I have another question.
So we are going to be
answering that question now.
The question is, many
places they give you an SLA.
They give you, oh, we guarantee
99.99% percent of availability.
But why not 100?
Could they do it?
MARK MANDEL: In theory, you
could have 100% availability
if you never changed any code.
In theory.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I, actually,
do not believe that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that is also true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Even if
you don't change any code,
if your system is available
through the internet
the internet is
not available 100%.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
So, like I said,
in theory you could
but there's lots of stuff that
can go wrong in the process.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the interesting thing
is that you could have a 100%
SLA, Service Level Agreement,
which means that if
your service does not
offer 100% availability it
means that they will somehow
compensate for it.
That is an SLA.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
doesn't mean they
will have 100% availability.
Because that is
literally impossible.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, as
you said stuff goes down
and things break.
But I think, also, it's
a good point that you're
going to want new features
to come into your application
or whatever it is that
you have to be building.
And any change you make is risk.
And there's nothing you
can really do about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we talked about this.
With Paul Newson, our
dear Paul Newson, on 59.
So if you're interested
in knowing more of this
that's definitely an
episode that you might
be interested in listening to.
But I think that the
most interesting thing
is what you were mentioning
before about what is actually
five nines, or six nines,
or what-- to start with,
five nines, does that mean
nine nine, and five more nines?
Or nine nine, dot,
and three nines?
Because it is ambiguous.
MARK MANDEL: Five
nines, 99.999%.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so
the two nines in the 99%
are already counted.
MARK MANDEL: They're all nines.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good, OK.
You never know.
MARK MANDEL: This
goes to a good point,
and Rokesh alluded
to in his question
when he was like, what does it
mean that Spanner isn't 100%.
Spanner has five
nines availability.
So 99.999% availability.
What does that mean for
mission critical applications?
So you sit back and
can actually sit down
and look at the numbers.
Wikipedia has a
great table on this
and we'll link it
in the show notes.
But for example, so
five nines per year
gives you 5 minutes
and 26 seconds,
or 5.26 minutes of downtime.
That's sort of what it means.
Or essentially 25 seconds per
month, which is not a lot.
And so the question
you have to ask
yourself is what is the
SLA of your application.
Rokesh uses the term
mission critical.
What does that mean?
Does your application have
to be up 100% of the time?
Some applications are
like that, and that's
certainly fair enough.
But can your application handle
five minutes of downtime,
or could you put in say a
caching layer or something
like that to
mitigate any downtime
from your back-end systems or
allow for some functionality,
but not all.
And I think those are
the sort of questions
that we need to be talking
about when we build software.
We can't just be sort
of hand-wavy and say,
it must be up all the time
because otherwise bad things
happen.
We have to think
back and say software
fails Come from the perspective
that software fails.
Let's go back and talk to John
Wilkes again because we can.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I was
exactly thinking about that.
The episode that we did with him
where basically, Borg and also
Kubernetes are built with the
whole idea of, software fails,
everything fails.
Let's build something that
is kind of reliable on top
of something that is not.
MARK MANDEL: Those are the
questions that should be asked.
That's pretty interesting.
When you actually
break it down though,
you look at the
nines availability,
like, two nines, so 99%.
That's 3.65 days per year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
starts to be a lot.
I mean--
MARK MANDEL: It does,
but that sort of like--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
guess that I am not
available that much as a person.
MARK MANDEL: That's
seven hours a month.
In some cases that could
actually be an OK SLA depending
on what it is you're doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, absolutely.
On the most available part,
if you get nine nines,
you get 31 milliseconds
per year of off time.
So basically, I wonder if
anyone has enough probes,
like, so often to--
MARK MANDEL: To guarantee it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, like actually
drop one of the probes, so
it's like 31 milliseconds off.
That is hard.
MARK MANDEL: I feel like
you would drop TCP packets.
And if you had to check it
some packet on that IP stream
would end up disappearing
and you're like, oh,
that's our SLA gone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah I get
that nine nines is basically--
nine nines and 100
are basically there.
They're basically the
same thing and they're
both pretty much unachievable.
If you have a service that
offers nine nines please let
us know.
We'd like to interview you.
I think that is a very
interesting set of requirements
to achieve that availability.
We'd love to talk to you.
MARK MANDEL: And find
out how you achieved it.
So yeah, to Rokesh,
I think what is
the requirements of your app?
What are your SLAs?
What do you need
to be able to do?
And what sort of failure
rate can your stuff require?
And that will tell
you exactly what
systems you can build on
top of and also how quickly
and how majorly
you can change them
while they're running as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
that goes back to,
as I said, the episode
with Paul Nielsen where
we talk about the
difference between SLO, SLA,
and actual availability.
So I guess that
answers the question.
MARK MANDEL: I think so too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I guess
it's time to say goodbye.
Before that, what are you up to?
MARK MANDEL: What am I up to?
So next week, East
Coast Games Conference.
We talked about that previously.
And then I'll be off
to Vector as well.
After that we we're
doing a fundraiser.
Extra life and Play
Crafting Game Jam
are doing some fun stuff
for kids in hospitals.
So we'll have two
weekends of that from--
and that's on the 5th of
May, and then again we
have another
fundraiser on the 13th.
And then after that I'm pretty
excited, I'm going to Sweden.
I'm going to Nordic
Games Conference.
So I'll be presenting
there as well.
And where are you off to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by the
time this episode comes out,
I'll probably be at the
airport waiting for my airplane
to fly to China.
I'm going to Shanghai
for GopherCon China,
and I'm going to be meeting
with some companies there.
But for now I don't have
any meet-ups organized,
which is fine.
Because probably I will end up
just attending some meet-ups up
there.
Then in May I will be in New
York for an Intel meeting,
but I will be also speaking
at the Google developer
group with Brett.
He will be speaking
about Cloud Functions.
I will be speaking about
Cloud Endpoints and gRPC.
So basically it's
a server-less day.
It's going to be lots of fun.
Also something that
I wanted to mention,
is that last week I released a
new episode of "Just For Funk."
People are loving it.
It's on the context package and
got already almost 5,000 views.
I'm pretty excited about
it, go check it out
if you are into
that kind of thing.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
All right, Francesc,
thank you again
for joining me for
yet another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: All right, and
we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]